Pro
[Silence]
see for
before a quick reminder before we get
started inshah make sure your cell
phones are turned off on the mute or
silence
Allah
abbb
[Silence]
Allah ill
Allah
ill
as muham
[Silence]
Al
f
[Silence]
allahar
ohar ill
[Silence]
alhamdulillah ald
subh
[Silence]
Allah
my dear brothers respected Elders
esteemed viewers and listeners beloved
youth mothers and sisters we thank Allah
subhana tala for keeping us life one
more day on the path of Islam on the and
allowing me and you to enter his house
and worship him in the manner that
pleases him I ask Allah subhana T to
accept from me and accept from us all
the little we do in his path a mean and
the bear witness there is no deity
worthy of worship except for Allah
subhana tala and Prophet Muhammad S
wasam is his last and final messenger
who surely Allah subhana T choose to
guide n can misguide him and whoever
chooses to misguide n can guide him back
to the path and we seek refuge in Allah
from darkness of ourselves and evil or
for Deeds for Allah is all knowing and
allseeing what his creation
does Allah disting distinguishes
whatever he Wills of his creation and to
him belongs all the wisdom and praise
and his creation and selection part of
magnifying Allah is honoring what he has
distinguished and favored and time is a
vehicle that is used for drawing Us near
to our Lord and Gathering provisions of
Good Deeds for her after among the best
ways of making our records and deeds
heavier is by obeying Allah subhana tala
during virtuous times Allah has chosen a
day that he has mentioned in his book an
entire Surah is named after it and like
any other day of the week it is the most
noble and the most honorable day as
theith
of mentions
the best day the sun rises in is the day
of Friday and Allah subhana tala
in has taken has told
us said the witness is Friday and the
witness is the day of on Friday
significant occur events have occurred
as Allah has completed his creation of
the heavens and the Earth
that he has mentioned in the
Quran in Allah says indeed Lord your
lord Allah is who created the heavens
and the Earth in six
days so as such we as Muslims and I with
all due respect and sincerity for
everybody I believe we do not honor the
day of Friday in the manner that needs
to be honored
in we are using the day of Friday as a
regular day event or as we live in the
west these days it is the start of the
weekend so most commonly you will hear
folks say it if somebody works in in a
different Health in a different field or
healthc care system they will tell you
oh today's tomorrow is Wednesday
tomorrow is my Friday that means the
start of their weekend it's time for
them to be off and we throw them the
word around it's supposed to be a
leisurely act and it's not supposed to
be a leisurely act if you look at
it theth
that wasam has enumerated on this topic
are immense there is a lot of a Hadi
that talk about the significance of the
day of
Friday and we do not give it the true
and due Justice for that day a day Allah
subhana ta'ala
chose to create Adam
in
right a day that Allah subhana tala
chose to
forgive
Adam and Allah
subh taught him the words to be forgiven
and then the Friday is the day the end
of time will
occur so it has a great significance to
it and we just go through it marking it
as a day that is the start of our
weekend that's fine you might have time
coming off and that's okay but that does
not make it not worthy enough for us to
prepare for that
day now if you look at the system in
Islam we are a lunar based calendar
based folks our day starts at sunset
when the M Salah is occurring that's the
start of our
day when do we open our
fast if the if you go by the moon
sighing they wait for the moon sighting
after and then
it's right you haven't fasted yet the
fast is going occur later but you're
already
praying and if it's cited for the you
stop that day that's it but is going to
be the next day it hasn't started yet so
our day starts at Sunset and
theam has told us what we should be
doing on that day and he
said increase
your your peace and blessings upon me on
this day so we start on the sunset we
start at the time of sunset on Thursday
night to continue get ready for the
Friday
morning then the Hadith mentions is that
you have to make a proper a of J on the
day of Friday to come and get prepared
for the Masid and wear from the best
that Allah has provided you from and
cleanse up in the best manner you can to
trim your nails and trim your hair and
come to the Masjid
prepare to meet to get the blessings of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and as such we are not doing True
Justice to
ourselves I give you a small
example I was reading a Hadith recently
and of course I was aware of the Dua
that we are supposed to read after we
finish
food all praises to Allah subhana tala
who fed us who gave us something to
drink to quench our thirst and he
created us Muslims you know the
significance of the Dua it is amazing if
you pay attention to it the Hadith
mentioned if you say the Dua after after
eating it Allah subhana T forgives all
of your
sins Ya Allah
amazing the mercy of Allah is
waiting for us to connect and get our
sins forgiven so who is not
connecting is it Allah or
us as the Quran says to to
oh Muhammad sallahu alai wasallam if
your servant if my servants ask you
about me yeah Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam tell him tell them I am close I
will respond to their prayer if they ask
me the condition is to ask
and we're not connecting in that manner
the ofam on the day of Friday
[Silence]
is
menam we are the last to come meaning
we are the last that have a prophet in a
book and a Shar that's it there's no
more Prophet coming there's no more Shar
coming even when
Isa comes he will be under the sh under
the rule and the guidance
ofam he will not bring a new religion he
will not bring a new book he will not
bring a new world order the world order
that was brought down byat is the
Everlasting one
and we will be the first ones on the day
of the on the day of judgment meaning
what we're the first people of
theam that will get their accounts done
and will enter the paradise
inshallah though they were given the
scriptures before us meaning the yahood
and Nar were had the scriptures before
us this is their day Friday which was
prescribed to them so Allah mentioning
Allah subhana told them the Friday is a
blessed day and that was the day that
was given to them as well
but they fought amongst themselves on
that day they fought amongst themselves
on that day and the Jewish Community
took the day of Saturday and the
Christians took day of Sunday to be
blessed for
them look at what Allah subhana is
lining up for us in a sense that what
details there are available for us to
follow you know I read a Hadith today
that was really really really really
hurtful in a sense that of I'm try to
cut it short because the Hadith is
extremely long and I don't think I will
have enough time to go through every
single thing that is mentioned in that
Hadith because we need some elaboration
on the Hadith as
well says
he says I heard wasallam say the best
day the sun rises in the day of Friday
Allah subh created Adam on that day and
that was the day Allah subhana
tala forgave his shortcomings and that's
the day Allah subhana tala took him back
meaning that his soul was taken away and
that's the day that day of Resurrection
be will be will be
established this this this part of the
Hadith is so profound he says he
continued to say that I heard the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
there is not a single creature that
Allah has created on the face of the
earth that is not in a panic mode when
the day of Friday begins before the
sunrise until the sun has risen they are
in a panic why are they in a
panic because they know the day of the
death day on the earth the end of the
Earth is a day of Friday that's the day
of Destruction and the sign of it is
what instead of the East the sun will
rise in the west so this creation
creation of Allah subhah wa ta'ala
from a minuscule thing that we cannot
see to the biggest animals we can see
and understand are petrified and
terrified of Allah's on that day and the
Hadith
continues except for the man he is
heedless he has no care that it is a day
of Friday
that if I'm not worshiping Allah from
time the sun has not risen to the sun
has come up it could be the last
day and as we're told
inam when the Sun rises in the west the
the door of the tobas is are closed
that's it there's no more Toba
accepted just as a person who is passing
away the time
of when the soul has reached right up
here and you give the person a water
even the water cannot go down the throat
that's it the time of Toba is over
now so we need to be a mindful people
and a mindful humans to the creation of
Allah subhana taala Allah subhana has
not created us just
because he created us for a
reason I have not created the humans and
the g kind except to worship
me the daily lives that we have the
things that are attached to our
sustenance from the Outlook it might
appear that is connected to my boss to
my organization to the company I work
for but that's just the appearance of
it that's just the appearance of it it
is not such it is not
so I would to remind you and
myself cuz I came to this country when I
was in high school so I'm old enough to
remember how my parents came and what we
had and what we did not
have I remind you that at that time we
survived Allah took care of us when we
had
nothing Allah has blessed us
immensely
immensely I swear to Allah subhana tala
if you sit in the office for one day and
you hear the problems of the community
members and people who come and ask W I
guarantee you you will tell me I have no
problems in my
life but that does not mean we become
heedless human beings Allah has not
blessed us us with the blessings that he
has given us to us for us to become a
person who is not thankful to Allah
[Arabic recitation]
imagine Allah created a system that is
for five prayers a day all staggered
through the time periods and the longest
period distance between two Salah is
between your workday starting and the
day the afternoon time your lunch hour
and then another long Stager is between
the time you go to bed and to wake up
for
f he gave us the mechanism in the
system but if I'm not we're not choosing
to act upon it whose fault is
it I said the Hadith is extremely
long I have a lot of more Hadith to
cover but the time flies Subhan Allah
when you're here I will stop the first
this inshallah
the point of a HBA is not a feel-good
sermon or a feel-good message the point
of a HBA is to have reflection upon it
after we leave this period I have your
attention maybe somewhat not even 100%
of it for less than 30 minutes and
that's all I get to have with probably a
lot lot of you guys they are present
here the takeaways are that whatever has
been said to day that you go home and
then you open the books of a Hadith you
open the Quran and then you start
reading
it and you figure out what that means
not that you have a distrust in the
speaker giving you the message but as
one of my beloved teachers I call him a
teacher because I I was impressed with
him at a very young age when I was
introduced to him may Allah subh have
rahma and mercy
immensely on his grave
ahed from South Africa may Allah subhana
tala Elevate his statuses in the Jenna
and may Allah provide him with the
highest of boats in the paradise and
Grant
him which roof is the of Allah subhana
tala he used to say you do not do that
research because you are you know
worried that a speaker is misspeaking or
misrepresenting but you want once you
look up that information that becomes
your knowledge and knowledge only
spreads if you share it with other folks
[Silence]
alhamdulillah theam mentions there is is
a time in the day of Friday when a
person asks Allah subhana tala accept
Allah grants him whatever he has asked
for granted it is not against the Shar
against the manners and the ethics of
Islam and making the
Dua and then a second Hadith mentions in
it's mentioned that seek that time in
the last hours
after so alhamdulillah alhamdulillah the
days are getting
shorter the time is getting shorter the
day ends faster now there isn't that
much time
between
and it's couple of hours but let's try
to connect to Allah subhana tala ask
Allah for our things that we need to ask
him for for whatever it is
sustenance our our children our house
our protection from all evil that exists
today all evil that exist
today you know I made this statement
several times and several of you have
asked and reached out to me afterwards
and said you know we feel the same way
I'm standing in the member of
in the mess I I swear to Allah subhana
tala it's been a weird half a
year since end of Ramadan things have
been literally Haywire for a lot of the
folks in the community there's has been
turbulence fam's issues health issues
job issues and other issues this is the
time to ask Allah subh to
reconnect and if you see a brother and
this is just a caution if you see a
brother engaged in VI on Salah don't go
and bother them
either yes it's good to
say went to the and if he's busy leave
him alone let Him worship Allah subhana
and connect after when he's done so
you're not bothering him during his
Quran in doing or maybe Salah by the way
I've done that I think the the doctor
the brother might be must be might be
here actually went up to the brother it
was Ramadan and I and I shook his hand
profusely because he was eating a tested
I thought he had done
and I realized after 3 minutes that
brother was still in Salah so I
apologized after I said I did not
understand you were in Salah please
forgive me so it happened so be mindful
of those issues around you we ask Allah
subhana taala for a we ask Allah subhana
tala first and foremost to cure the ills
in our community may that be mental
health issues job issues husband and
wife issues children issues we ask Allah
subh to relieve those stresses amongst
ourselves and our brothers and sisters
first and foremost in this community and
the Muslim overall as you might know
I might not know brother mak's mom is in
the hospital she had surgery
alhamdulillah was successful we visited
her she's recovering well we ask Allah
subhana tala to bless us with her with
health and and recovery and bring her
back home and she recovers fully and
swiftly a mean and we ask Allah subh any
Muslim who is suffering anywhere in the
world with health ISS may Allah subh
grant them a full recovery and a swift
recovery as you might have heard in the
announcements my aunt from my father's
side has passed
away may Allah subh bless her with the
highest abose in the Jen may Allah
forgive her shortcomings and may Allah
subhana ta'ala Elevate her statuses as
we speak may Allah subh have mercy upon
her grave expand it and make it light
and and and ease in that grave of hers
am mean
we ask Allah subhana tala to unite us as
a single
ofam in the manner thatat had envisioned
for us to be United under the banner
of Muhammad we ask Allah subhana to do
not take us from this world until he
himself Allah is content and happy with
us and when he takes us away from this
world the last words that roll off our
tongue are Muhammad may Allah subh make
us from the people who unite hearts and
not divide Hearts we ask Allah to make
us from the people who provide Solutions
not difficult to our brothers and
sisters we ask Allah subhana tala to
provide deliverance and ease and and
mercy to our brothers and sisters
fighting in Gaza first and foremost in
the West Bank we ask Allah subhana tala
to provide ease and mercy and
deliverance to our brothers and sisters
in Sudan who are currently going through
starvation and other issues may Allah
subh grant them the AIA and and ease in
this world and the Hereafter we ask
Allah subh to provide deliverance and
success to our brothers and sisters who
are struggling from China to Burma to
Kashmir to India to anywhere else in the
world they are fighting through right
now may Allah subh T help them and Aid
all of our Muslim brothers and sisters
who are under oppression with the aid of
his Mala his angels that we do not see
and do not count we ask Allah subhana
tala to to forgive our shortcomings as
an we ask Allah subh to forgive us
and our forefathers on this day of
Friday and enter us together in Paradise
ask Allah subhana tala to gather us like
he has gathered us today in this Masjid
in this peace and ser Serenity in the
day of K in the highest Paradise of
jenas and we remind you at the end of
this Dua that if you get there and you
do not find your brothers and sisters in
that paradise you ask Allah subh them to
be brought to you oh Muslims Allah subh
T has commanded you and the Jin in the
Quran by giving you a command that he
himself first and foremost fulfilled he
said
[Silence]
please move forward
ill
[Silence]
please straighten your minds fill the
gaps in between may Allah subh have
mercy upon us all a
meanb alul
[Silence]
mean
for
[Silence]
Allah
abbar allahar
[Silence]
allar alhamd
amen
[Silence]
allar
Allah
abbar allahar
[Silence]
allahar allahar
Allah
[Silence]
alum
my dear brothers and sisters assalamu
alikum I I got a couple of very
important requests and i' you to
take a moment to to at least reflect on
it the most important part is
remember we have children in the school
here in the building we have children
that are coming to school and that is
every day of the week almost in
including you know even we have a Sunday
school so that means that we have young
children all the way throughout the week
around the building and if we are
driving carelessly or in a hurry we may
end up causing a damage or hurting
somebody and then we regretting it so we
really are requesting you please be very
careful Drive slowly and be very careful
about making sure there's no nobody
along the way who may get get impacted
or hurt we have several complaints or
concerns or situations that have Arisen
from this so I'm taking the time to at
least request you take care of it as
much as you can and if you think
somebody else who is not here today is
doing something that could cause a
problem take a moment to pass this
message along
inshallah the second part is the the
intercom that is used used for the
school purposes only for the children in
the school so we cannot use that for
other purposes and that is the
requirement from the school perspective
and it's really also helpful for the
teachers so we are not bothering
everybody and it is being managed only
for the school purposes so make sure we
follow that rule
the front door that is the glass
doors during jamaa and during the school
hours they will be closed normally so
don't use that so we are going to make
sure that during Juma you have to go
around to to get to that because that is
again another situation that we want to
make sure that children are being safe
and we will keep evaluating the the way
we manage the traffic inshallah
throughout the
building construction is still in
progress right so if you are just making
sure that nothing is going to cause a
damage or hurt to somebody so whether
it is from the construction or it is
from our actions
inshallah please also you can donate
generously for the Masjid construction
the that is for the expansion of the
school inshallah donate generously for
other causes also a brother who is from
Syria he has
requested assistance medical assistance
and if you are able to help please
contact Brother Ahmed jabber or Imam
Hassan he this is the family in Syria
and they have some medical need that can
be that can be provided
[Silence]
that's not enough after seven
nights it's hard to recover from Night
Shift
[Silence]
Sol sometimes
how are you doing nothing good
[Silence]
don't stress too much
relax
[Silence]
e
e e
[Silence]
you